à nouveau recours collectif vient d'être
déposée contre la compagnie apport on
accuse l'entreprise de rendre le iphone
4s obsolète et ce intentionnellement
bonsoir mathieu cellule alors recours
collectif ambitieux et ses réels et
normalement on va rappeler les faits
donc m luhrmann un new yorkais qui
accuse apple d'avoir volontairement
ralenti son iphone 4s
après la mise à jour du système
d'exploitation ios 9 faut quand même
rappeler que l'iphone 4s est un
téléphone que plus de quatre ans dans
technologie mais est-ce qu'on peut aller
jusqu'à dire que ces appareils ont été
pensés ces téléphones ont été pensés
pour devenir désuet plus rapidement fait
parler d'obsolescence programmée c'est
peut-être un peu le fort parce qu'on
peut pas dire qu'à part un mini pièce
dans l'ordre dans le téléphone qui vont
briser après la fin de la garantie
sauf que quand on va voir les
spécialistes du jailbreaking donc du
déverrouillage de téléphones ils sont
unanimes ils disent on est sur des
téléphones connie mack microprocesseurs
qui sont relativement poussif pour pour
pour aujourd'hui et donc on leur oblige
de rouler dès 6 ans les oblige à rouler
des systèmes d'exploitation qui sont
extrêmement qui consomme beaucoup de
ressources dans beaucoup de procès
beaucoup de commandes beaucoup de
fonctionnalités mais on serait pas
obligé d'en avoir autant et il faut dire
aussi qu'une fois qu'on a fait la mise à
jour on peut pas d installer cette mise
à jour leur revenir donc à au système
d'exploitation antérieurs ce qui fait
que de facto le téléphone devient assez
difficile à faire fonctionner il est
donc oui on s'en rend compte en tout nos
téléphones que sur les android
les riffs on danse raconte qu'après un
certain moment ils sont plus loin
mais est ce que quand on parle de
déverrouillage qui est assez compliqué à
faire est-ce que c'est légal est ce que
c'est souhaitable c'est légal au canada
c'est souhaitable ça dépend ce que vous
voulez faire avec votre téléphone c'est
sûr que on peut moduler la mise à jour
si on déverrouille on peut décider
d'installer certaines choses et pas
d'autres ça ouvre quand même la porte à
des failles de sécurité il faut dire une
fois qu'on a fait ça la garantie n'est
plus valide alors c'est quand même un
pensez y bien quand on fait ça et est ce
qui existe des solutions de rechange en
existe oui des solutions de recherche de
gens qui sont prêts et que ce problème
une grande tendance ce sont les
téléphones modulable alors d'une firme
néerlandaise qui a mis sur le marché le
faire faune de
un téléphone équitable les métaux qui
font partie de sa composition viennent
de mines qui respecte les droits des
travailleurs et aussi faut dire qu'on
peut changer des éléments du téléphone
sans avoir à changer le téléphone au
complet on peut enlever la caméra à
mettre une nouvelle changer l'écran à
mettre un nouveau changer le
microprocesseur et aussi google qui est
sur les blocs de départ avec un projet
qui s'appelle le google art a donc un
téléphone modulable et les mises à jour
ou s'ils seront modulables
on parle d'environ 800 dollars pour un
téléphone qui dure cinq ans c'est quand
même à considérer pour les gens qui sont
un peu tanné de changer à tous les deux
ans et comme je le disais il ya beaucoup
de consommateurs
merci beaucoup a le désir céline